advice from Larry Ellison on the
entrepreneurs mindset when you're the
first person whose beliefs are different
from what everyone else believes you're
basically saying I'm right and everyone
else is wrong that's a very unpleasant
position to be in it's at once
exhilarating and at the same time an
invitation to be attacked come to your
own judgments don't simply conform to
conventional ways of thinking to
conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting a lot of
things are based on fashion even
morality at times is based on fashion
whether there's scientific principles or
moral principles or business ideas or
product ideas you have to think things
out for yourself I do not give
fashionable answers to questions that's
what shocks people when they ask you a
question and expect everyone to answer
it exactly the same way whenever you
give your own answer what you really
believe to be true rather than the
fashionable answer these people are
shocked or amused or even horrified to
learn more about the entrepreneur
mindset test checkout zuga zero zero
zero in the link below